fusionner plusieurs services afin de
réaliser des économies
c'est le principe de l'établissement
interdépartemental yvin hauts-de-seine
avec un budget qui devrait tourner
autour de 15 5 millions d'euros en 2019
les démarches de rapprochement et de
coopération vont se poursuivre entre les
deux départements
on prend ce qui a eu lieu dans le
département qui est la mieux traités par
exemple nous dans les hauts-de-seine
on a beaucoup gagné au système
d'insertion des yvelines et donc nous
nous avons harmonisé de dispositifs et
nous prenons celui des yvelines qui est
meilleur que le nôtre
créée en février 2016 2018 a été la
première année complète de
fonctionnement de cette structure
les orientations budgétaires porté
notamment sur l'entretien et
l'exploitation du réseau routier des
deux départements
il s'agit du plus gros poste de dépense
pour l'instant nous n'avons réalisé
d'économies que sur le secteur routier
où ce sont plusieurs millions d'euros
qui ont été économisés
c'est un petit établissement public
interdépartemental comparé aux grandes
activités qui sont dans les deux
départements donc c'est au fil du temps
au fil des transferts que ces économies
vont se faire de plus en plus importante
au cours des prochains mois de nouvelles
fonctions seront mutualisés l'éducation
et la commande publique
les présidents des deux départements
s'engageront également dans des projets
des initiatives communes
le vote du budget primitif lui est
prévue le 6 février 2019